Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode Live.
This is episode three of the
series,
I guess, clustered.
A show where we give perfectly functioning and
working Kubernetes clusters to
members of the community, and ask them to
break them with the intention of me and
a friend joining me to try and fix
them as best as we can.
Now, before we get started, I would please
encourage you all to subscribe and click the
bell on YouTube. This helps other people find
this content
The YouTube algorithms need a little bit of
nudge to show people that this is good
TV.
And finally, there is a Discord channel where
you can come and participate in the chat.
We're also giving away a clustered t shirt
today. So you've got about one hour to
join a clustered channel and register or by
enter the draw by clicking that little emoji
guy on the post.
Oh,
please do that. Now, today
I am joined by Michael
from AWS. We're gonna do our best to
fix these broken clusters.
Would you like to just give us a
quick introduction about yourself and then we'll pick
up from there?
Absolutely.
Thank you so much for having me on
the show, Dave. That's really a big honor.
And,
yeah, I'm excited. I don't know quite
what to expect. I watched the previous installment,
so I have some idea. But I also
saw the messages on Twitter, and I was
like, oh, I'm really scared. So yeah.
Now
I'm I'm just excited. Let's let's get into
that. Yeah. Yeah. It's one of those things
that, you know, there there's I I don't
wanna say infinite number of ways to break
a clusters, but there there's a lot of
ways that someone can break these clusters. And
I think we've seen a very good variety
so far, and I think there's there's so
much more that we can be put up
against.
But I'm glad you're here because
you have a wealth of Kubernetes experience there
that I'm hoping we can tap into
and share some of that knowledge with the
people that are viewing and joining
in for them Alright.
Cool. So
let's
Let me share my screen.
So one of the things we want these
episodes not just to be entertaining, but to
also help other people. So there is a
clustered repository on gitlab.com.
We add
little reports that show kinda what went wrong.
You feel free to read through these.
Sometimes there's a lot of detail here that
really show what was done to the cluster,
the best way to fix it. So hopefully
this is the viable resource moving forward as
well.
But of course there are no readmes, there
are no post mortems for the two clusters
that we're working with today.
So our first cluster is cluster three.
This
is by Justin Garrison,
who has,
I don't know if kindly broken it is
the right word, but has
dedicated some of their time to break those
words and we're gonna do our best to
fix it. The way that we're gonna do
that is by hopefully lots of communication
and one of my favorite projects, Teleport.
We both have access to Teleport here,
meaning we can and hopefully can click connect,
join us route, have an SSH session that
we share and verbalize as much of our
thoughts as possible.
So normally the first thing I would do
is
jump into this directory here. This is the
tooling that I use to prepare all of
the clusters. And there's a kubect config here.
And I always like to run a get
nodes and see what happens. Should we try
that first?
Sure.
Is that is that the first thing you
would do? Have you got any special tricks,
any commands you'd prefer?
I usually,
as a first step, look at version. So,
you know, just version.
Just to have an idea, you know, am
I on a 1.15
cluster or 1.2 or whatever. So okay. That's
something.
Well, at least we have our first problem.
That's very nice. Yes. Yes.
Cool.
I
also usually look around in terms of,
you know,
CRDs and and stuff like that.
But, you know, keep cutting that notes is
also a good good way to see coming
from the infrastructure
perspective. Well, that's that's not gonna work then,
is that? Don't think based on the certificate
error. Yeah. Probably
not.
So it looks like our certificate has expired.
We cannot speak to the API server.
As
pair, we're gonna have to just get onto
the box. So let's get this teleport session
available.
Alright.
Let me zoom in on this a little
bit.
Now,
you wanna just
type something. Let's make sure we've got a
a working pairing setup.
Okay.
Did you click connect or did you go
to join session?
I am on o o three. I am
on that session.
In there.
Maybe I need to reconnect.
I know you've got a different session. I'll
join yours. Okay. Let me It's okay. Okay.
Let me close this Yeah.
We're
now here, echo.
Well Yep. I don't need to actually fix
that and type it, but
alright. Well,
what do you wanna do first?
So all that we know so far is
that
we can't talk to the control plane. Right?
And
what we've done now, we have SSH into
one of the nodes where control plane components
are
located. Right? That's what we
that's what we did with
with the
the SSH.
I just seen a comment from Justin's and
he was as kind as possible, which is
not filling me with any confidence
No.
Whatsoever. Not
at So
we are now
in that session that we see on the
screen. We are on a control plane node.
Right? We are on a control plane node.
That is correct. So
why don't we just have a look around
what is running there? So, you know,
PS
and then looking for control plane components
like, you know, the Yeah.
I normally look for the first.
Yeah. Yeah. That's that's a pretty pretty so
it's there.
It is there. Yeah. We we do have
an API server. Yes.
Yes. Yes.
We see
what we would expect there. Right?
All
all the things.
I love how calm you are.
I'd say in my head, I am screaming
already and you're just so collected.
I'm no. The thing is I'm looking at
the tiny screen on our internal one rather
than on the big one. So if that
if that
if I increase the font size, then you
also
you will literally have the same right here.
So I shouldn't be doing that. Sorry. Okay.
Cool.
So what do we see here?
Okay.
Anything that stands out for you? Well,
we we did see
that the start had expired.
Justin's jumped in just to say that because
we're using teleport,
there is no MOTD. That is correct. So,
let's let's run MOTD. Okay.
Oh, why is my thing being a bit
weird?
Well, that's not a command.
So we need to
I'm just gonna reload this. My session's been
a bit funny.
There we go.
There should be an MOTD file. Right? Yeah.
Help.
So,
I can't get the cluster to work. I
have tried running
trying to deploy
some Kubernetes example.
Right. And then exposing it. And then there's
another problem. Can't resolve DNS.
Right.
But given that we have not yet
access to the
API server,
there is really no point. Right? I mean,
that's
that's once we have fixed the access to
the API server. Yeah. I think we're gonna
have to take a look at these SERPs
and see if we can see what the
expiration time on them is
and then let me just move that up.
I can see that it's kinda clapping on
the stream.
Do you wanna try it then? We'll go
take a look at these search. Go
ahead. That's fine. I'm I'm trying to
assess how evil how evil Justin might
be. What
what beyond the obvious could be there? Yeah.
So we have this inside, etcetera, Kubernetes. We
have the PKI folder. This is where I
would expect to find all of the servers.
Now,
the API server is probably the one we
wanna kind of inspect. I
can never ever
ever remember the open SSL commands to query
that. Do you know it or should I
pop open a quick to go? I know.
Yes. We we have to look at that.
Know.
It's either in my history it's either in
my history or I have some
some cheat sheet somewhere. I don't remember
these things.
Oh, what? Paste
is a bit funny. Let's try one more
time and I'll save it manually.
Yeah. That's not working. Okay. So it's open
SSL x five zero nine.
Oh, no. It's testing. It's just the file
doesn't exist. I'm just being really
silly. Alright. Now we wanna take a look
at the API server key,
I believe.
Nope. That is not our trusted certificate.
Let's try this there.
Alright. There we go.
Our certificate expired. Oh,
he's tamed it well. He's had expire right
before. Yeah.
Nice.
Nice. Nicely done. Thank you.
So, we're gonna have to renew this certificate.
Nice.
How do we do that?
Open SSL.
I wish it was just is there a
cheat sheet? That's what we need.
There we go.
I always like when I kinda came up
with the idea for this show, I always
said to anyone that I mentioned it to,
I really hope people don't mess with the
certificates. It's like the one
thing. It's I mean, nobody ever remembers this
What what people really heard was messing with
the certificate. Gotcha. I I have you covered.
I'm gonna mess with the certificate.
So we don't wanna generate any key. We
just wanna It's it's
it's not it's not super
unlikely. Right? These things happen. Right? I mean,
it's it's not
totally,
you know,
made up. So
So we're getting lots of, I mean, the
chat's hard to keep up with,
but Justin has dropped us. We hadn't, maybe
I don't need to renew this after all,
because he just left us one liner and
yeah.
Oh, he did. Very kind of him.
So That's a good question. Are they expired
on all control plane nodes?
Yeah.
That came in from
Duffy. Yeah. We should probably have to check
that as well. So
I think
I think Justin has been very kind to
us. There is this .APIserver.CRT.
I mean, I could just blatantly copy that
over the top and hope,
but you know, we do have that open
SSL command that we check the expiration date.
Why not? Yeah. Why don't don't we check
that first?
Open SSL and
run it against the the stock version and
see if that's a better date.
You're far too kind. Okay.
I was just, you know, reading from the
left, like, February 18, like, you and then,
oh, '22. Okay. We're good.
Alright. So we could just Thank you very
much. Yeah. That that
I'm glad I didn't have to try and
remember those comments.
So now that we have replaced, we had
a broken cert. We have replaced it. We
just have to restart the API server.
Is that all I have to do?
I'm trying to catch up with the Yes.
Yes. So we can just Well,
don't know. Maybe the kubelet's already restarted up
in the search change. I'm not sure. So
we can always just restart the kubelet.
Oh, there's a key too.
Thanks Justin.
We need to move apiserver.
Key to apiserver.
Key.
Alright. Let's restart the cubelet and hope for
the best.
Yes. He was very kind, but that just
means that the main problem he wants us
to fix isn't the steps. We
still got two
more things. Exactly.
All right. Now we're on a control plane
node. That means we have access to
kubernetes/ecc/kubernetesadmin.com.
Ever API server is working, I would expect
this to be able to run get nodes
now.
Computer still says no data API server restart.
Let's just check.
No. That hasn't restarted, has it? March start.
Okay.
My favorite command, till nine.
Sure. Why why don't you do the sledgehammer?
That that always helps. I could've said, I
think, guess, but, you know, like
so the capability should detect that missing is
a static manifest. It should be restarted automatically.
I'm just trying to rewatch on this n
one.
And hopefully that goes back up.
I've never killed minus nine to API server
before, so I'm hoping there was no other
I hope that wasn't too harsh.
We also got a
comment.
So
yeah, QPDM and it faces search API server
would have, I believe, we proficient or regenerated
the search.
I believe if we had done that, we'd
probably have to do it across all the
nodes. I'm assuming we maybe won't have to
do that by using the ones that were
preferred.
Thanks.
My accent is kind of Scottish
and kind of not.
That
kind of worried me there. Where's my API
server, Mako?
It didn't come back.
Right.
Okay. So
Oh, the the hint there also mentioned it.
Right? You need to move
the manifest QAPI
server out
and then in again and then put it
back again. But
we restarted the Qplet.
But apparently, the the static pod is not
picked up if if
if it's not moved out in again. So
if you go to Oh, yeah. The comments
seem pretty everybody is yelling that. So
I will I will just do as I'm
told.
Okay. So I think that's interesting then. I
I would have I assumed
restarting the kuplet would have checked to make
sure that all the static manifests were running
and it would appear that that's not the
case. So that was just a silly assumption
on my part.
So
it's a valuable it's a valuable insight. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. Definitely.
So, I've moved it back in and now
we do the wait. I'm not very good
at the waiting stage.
Justin says, is the cubelet running?
Oh, didn't touch it, but we can check.
We do have a cubelet. Yes.
It was restarted a few moments ago, which
is what we expect. Okay.
I mean, I definitely could
Should we check the API server?
Adrian's
just went, I've broken it more. Yeah. I
mean, that's always I was actually more worried
about copying the key on top of the
cert or the cert on top of the
key or messing up something when I was
restoring the certs, but I think I got
that okay. So
I'm not sure
what the problem is gonna be right now.
Like one more. Okay, that's definitely not coming
back.
So,
I need to stop watching the comments and
focus on fixing this. This
isn't part of the plan. No, it's not
part of my plan either. Right.
Let's get this API server back up and
running.
A restart of the kubelet should check all
the static manifests are running. We have even
removed the manifest. So, let's try one more
thing before we go into panic, before I
go into panic mode, sorry. You're pretty cool.
I'm gonna move this out, restart the Qplet
and then drop it back in
just to see if we can kinda take
things along a little bit here.
So Just just that this wasn't part of
the fact.
Alright. Stay the same. Ian, no worries worries.
We said forty minutes each. So no matter
what, after forty minutes, we we switch over.
And it looks like we're gonna spend the
first forty minutes in the chat. Have servers
on it. Something.
Alright. Where where where are we? We're not
gonna split this over too because we're very
lucky and that we have all the tech
conk and Justin joining us in the comments.
We will just really leverage any help if
we start to run out of time. So
Alright. Kubernetes
Kubernetes is a team sports. Right? I mean,
that's that's clearly like I don't wanna go
walk alone.
So moving it back I moved it back
and I'm trying to work out whether I
want to restart the kubel one more time
or just kinda see if it's gonna detect
that. Now we could always pull up the
logs, right? So let's do In fact, we
should have done this sooner.
Let's see what the kubelet is actually
dropping into our terminal here.
So it's not finding the node.
Potentially messing with the certs is a little
bit more dangerous than we expect.
Messing with the certs,
never do that.
So the kubelet is trying to speak to
the API server. The API server is not
there.
The problem is not the kill nine Adrian,
come on.
We've all killed nine a few processes before.
All right.
The problem could be that we just need
to do the search on all of these.
So I'm gonna quickly jump on to the
other two control plane nodes.
Let's just check the search, see if we've
got the same thing. Let's see if we
can get something online here. So
PKI, do we have dot files? We do.
Okay. So, cert on top of cert
and key it on top of key
and
API server.
Okay.
Do we know the number for SIGHUP?
I'll do this I'll do it a bit
more gently this time.
Can I just do stick? I can't remember
if there's a dash flag for doing that,
but let's see.
SIGHUP
number.
One. Got it. Okay. Cal one.
And the process isn't there anymore. So it
looks like it was restarted this time. Yeah.
Okay. So control plane
node two seems to be coming together a
bit better.
Let's do this one,
back into our PKI directory. We've got one
more dot cert to put over dot cert
and one more dot key to put over.
Oh, I copied. I panicked there so much.
Right, okay.
I was like, don't do that thing you
just said you weren't gonna do.
PS AUX.
And I'm gonna monitor this one as well
to see if this is auto restarted. So
this was started thirty one minutes ago.
Nope. Okay. Let's do kill one and process.
Okay. So that should be a sick hop
here.
That's been up for three seconds. Okay.
Now let's come back onto this one. This
is the one where nothing worked.
Correct.
And still
nothing.
Alright. We can ignore that one tonight. Do
you wanna join the session on K67?
K67,
yep. Coming.
And
we'll see if,
I'll just reload it. It's really weird. Like
when it must be a bug. I don't
know if it's Firefox or something else. Okay.
Kubernetesadmin.conf
get nodes.
Okay. Cool.
I possibly That's the one that is yeah.
I possibly broken that one. I'm not sure
how I've managed it.
Not sure what's gonna with that static manifest,
but I'm gonna ignore it for now.
Do we have the MOTD on all the
machines?
Okay. We do. So let's just work from
this one.
Sorry.
You
need to pass in we should alias.
Let me do alias k equals cube control
dash dash cube config
and I'll just save as a lot of
pin
version.
Oh. There we go. Sorry. I I
remembered 1.2
that was from from your machine locally.
All good. All good. I I thought maybe
he has he has messed with that as
well. Okay. Cool.
Cool. So we should tackle problem one first.
Alright? Let's Yeah. Let's see if we can
work this in order. So
it says that they've tried to do an
apply of this Kubernetes deployment. So should we
and that's probably worked, but they've tried to
expose it and that hasn't worked.
If we run a get pods,
we we actually do have the deployment. So
there's engine next. Can we quickly before we
do that, can we quickly do a
it's just a a really
wide
look. Oh, okay. There's something.
Okay.
That's maybe a little bit
I like to do
get all minus a, meaning across all namespaces
to get a, like, wide look to see
what's running across everything.
Just to have a bit of a feeling,
you know, okay.
Using Cilium here, even Hubble is installed,
The WordPress and other things. So one of
the things, like, you know, just looking around
a little bit to see if anything,
you know, stands out.
Okay.
So
when I did the m o t d
and it says it's expecting a load balancer,
I'm assuming then that the problem is
is this pending what they want us to
debug?
Yeah. Let's have a let let's describe the
engine x deployment.
Okay.
No events. No nothing. Looks pretty standard.
Right. And the service? Yeah.
As we see, internet deployment.
Location
field. Alright. So we have in the event
an
a message that the metal l b controller
is unhappy. So let's have a look at
the metal l b controller.
What do we have?
Yeah. Metal l b system.
Name space. So let's let's
use that. Right?
Config.
Use
this is
add on paper.
Config.
Use
oh, without all these plugins, I'm really
Well, we have our alias. So why don't
we just do
this and then for the sake of
not remembering how to use that thing, we
can just do metal l b system. So
now your case should be there. So
there you go. Fire away. Cool.
So
shall we have
so what is the
controller using the deployment here? Right?
Are we in the
We have a
we have a speaker
daemon set and a controller deployment.
Our controller deployment is failing because of a
node affinity.
Oh, we are not in the in the
middle.
So get context essentially lists all the context
there. Right? And we are currently, as you
can see here, not in the metal.
So We are. I just I just changed
the alias to pass in the namespace rather
than update the context.
Oh, okay. Okay.
Oh, I I I forgot that you prefer
sledgehammers.
Okay.
So what I tried to figure out was
what the owner of so you did get
pods. Right?
So we have these pods.
Right?
Yes. And
I wanted to see
who owns these pods. Is it I'm I'm
not that familiar with with metal l b.
The speaker is a daemon set and the
controller is a deployment code controller.
Okay. So if you say
it's gonna play here. Right? Yeah. And I
think it's got affinity that it doesn't want
scheduled together, which is why we're seeing so
many of them
failing to schedule.
These are nice.
So,
given I'm pretty familiar with running Kubernetes on
Equinix Medal.
I
I think there's no defending on the controller
is potentially
a red heading
and what I want to confirm is that
our CCM is actually running, which is what
would be requesting the Elastic IP from
Equinix Medal.
Right. But you're essentially
you you know
already, like, but how do you get there?
Right? How do you get from
seeing
that message
in service?
Right? But the the message we saw in
in the service that says, okay. You know,
the the metal will be controller has some
issue.
Jumping to the conclusion that you just did,
I I guess that's that's maybe useful for
people to to see. Right? How did you
get there? How did you besides that you
know it.
Yeah. So,
like, when I see this, I think, yeah,
the no definite is a problem, we do
have one running
controller. So my thought process is, like, I'm
actually not that worried about that. The speakers
are okay.
The error that we see when we describe
the service
sorry, I'm gonna have to retweet our alias,
my sledgehammer, sorry.
So I can just get that back. So
if we describe our service,
which we know is
failing,
it says it can't get an IP address.
Now, the thing that is responsible for getting
an IP address here for a load balancer
service is the cloud controller manager.
So my hypothesis says he's removed our cloud
controller manager or broken it in some way.
But then let's check if that
So we should see our packet cloud controller
manager running here.
Yep. And it's been running for fourteen days.
I was kinda hoping to see
that broken. Have a look at the logs.
Right? Let's let's have a look at the
logs.
If there is anything in in the logs
of the packet cloud controller manager.
Yeah. Maybe we should do it. I've control
c that but we'll need to give it
a second I think. Right. I was gonna
add a sense to it.
So when is that from? That's from that's
from today. Okay. So
we
ah.
Okay.
So the API token that our cloud controller
manager is using to speak to the cloud
provider API to get us an Elastic IP
is now unauthenticated. Right.
So we have the line here
that there is an invalid authentication token there.
Right? Yes. But the controller tries to speak
with the packet API and
so
something in the controller.
There should be a config map and the
cube system namespace
that has
the details that we need
for that to work.
Now we could theoretically
get into and retrieve.
Okay. I'm I'm just kidding.
Let's let's let's
where where does that config map come from?
Like, it's
how do you create it? I'm not that
familiar with
Yeah. So I think we can just recreate
it manually.
Now, this is where Justin doesn't know the
setup and I do and
this is actually more painful than I actually
wanted it to be because, you know, as
much as I trust the people I give
these clusters to, I don't trust them. No.
Don't trust them. So, there's project
keys for each,
but let's just check. In fact, Waleed, I
think you and I just have to say
my dear at the same time there. It's
not actually a config map. It's a secret,
isn't it? So,
yeah. There is a packet cloud config.
Right.
So But it's also fourteen days old, right?
There is nothing
nothing changed there.
That is true. Yeah. Just that you wanna
confirm that we are working on the right
problem here and I'm not
working on something that isn't relevant
before I go trying to before I go
flashing the auth token from this config anyway
and then trying to fix something that isn't
actually correct.
But we looked at the CCM logs. We
know that it's trying to request an IP
and it can't. Right. The authentication is the
problem. That's config map. That's secret, sorry.
Feels to me like we're looking in the
right place, but you're right. The fourteen days
on it is when I I
I wonder if he's just modified the time
in I
wonder if he's been that sneaky.
Justin confirmed it's it's a missing token. Right?
But
somehow I think it has not
much to do with that secret here.
I mean, given that it hasn't been touched.
Ah, what if you modify the CCM deployment
and then
change them the configuration?
You
think he's that sneaky? Yeah. Let's have a
look at the deployment. That's
I think yeah. He he may be mean,
but he's not like cool.
Fourteen days as well. And he's also I
know we're we're pushing our forty minute mark
here. Right? So thank you for the tips,
Justin. But he said, he's surprised the secret
doesn't say it was modified and edited. That's
probably a bug. So I hope we found
the bug. Would be awesome.
So this secret has I see what you
been modified. Let's let's fix it. Right? So
we can do edit secret. And I don't
mind flashing this. This token is not gonna
live much more than this episode anyway. So,
edit secrets.
This
there is my token cloud dash s a
dot json.
Well, no. It's not a bug because it
what it lists what the list view does,
it shows the creation timestamp, not the the,
you know
Last modified one. That's right. Right.
So,
is cloud dot se.
Json, is that what we're looking for? Let's
check
kube system,
edit, deploy, packet,
cloud,
CCM.
What was the packet cloud?
Let's just run get deploys again.
I'm not gonna remember.
Packet cloud control machine. Edit deploy. Yeah. And
I'll just copy and paste.
Alright. So what secret is this trying to
bring in?
Secret.
So that's just the I could cut configure.
Yep.
Packet cloud config. Yeah, that's the right name.
It's not specifying sub keys. So let's just
go to the volume mount.
So
we can just add dot JSON.
Okay.
Get deploy.
Is that restarted yet?
Get pods. Probably need to yeah. Oh, No.
Nice.
Don't we all love to see crash loop
back up?
I thought I got that okay. Hold on.
Oh yeah. It looked it looked good. Did
you did you store?
Oh,
wait. That's the mount path.
That is wrong.
Dot JSON. Yeah. Dot JSON. Yeah. No. No.
That's the volume then.
I'm not gonna use that.
Volume.
Okay,
let's revert this so that I've not touched
it.
Yeah.
Yeah. So, main path is to a directory
called CloudSA.
That is the name of the volume, isn't
it? Yeah.
Yeah.
So, the file name that the CCM is
affecting us.
Alright, let's get the logs again. I feel
like we're missing something here.
Yeah,
what are we missing?
Sends 10 ms,
invalid authentication token.
Now he might have just changed the path.
Don't
know that off the top of my head.
I'm gonna So just just said he deleted
data dot token from the secret.
So
let's
get to the
secret.
Alright.
I never told you how much I hate.
That's sure.
We're all together in it. No worries.
So is this just supposed to be called
token?
I'm gonna check another one.
I can't do that. Don't have one handy.
Let's have another broken one.
Okay. I'm
not entirely sure.
Where does the CCM live?
There we go. Is there a
Where is the secret?
I'll just check the code because I'm gonna
drive myself around in circles here.
So I'm going to declare this a, does
this have an example of kind secret?
Nope.
Alright. Let's grab this.
That looks fine.
That's the unbase 64
what?
The
value of cloud is a JSON.
Marcus has a nice suggestion.
Okay.
Alright. Let's tackle his second problem.
Okay. So we theoretically have an answer for
the search third one. Right? So that's
that's something.
Prompt is there's
no DNS.
Yeah. Okay. So Justin changed the token.
Yeah. That's what I was trying to alluding
to when I said that I'm aware of
the setup and you're not, but I used
very specific tokens for each project and then
Okay.
Dropping that back in
a little bit more difficult than I'd actually
like it to be. Anyway.
How are we doing time wise?
You said
Yeah. We'll we'll give let's see if we
can fix this tech problem in five minutes
and move on to the other cluster. Yep.
Let's time that. That that makes sense. Yeah.
Yeah. So, there's no DNS to say the
cluster.
Me jump on this. They want us to
run this command.
And
I need to use case. I get the
token.
We have a command prompt
and then to dig Kubernetes
and we didn't get a response. So our
cluster DNS
is using the correct IP address, looks like
for internal
DNS,
but not resolving.
So, what's step one here then, Michael?
Sorry. I tried to to get onto that
session but somehow it's it's disconnected.
Are we not in the same session? Oh,
okay. I k f I thought but I
if I say join here then it says
now I am. Right.
That's the one. Right?
Yeah. He's
I'll
just reload. Okay.
Yes. So Cool.
We got a hint. Okay. So let's use
the hint since we're time boxed here
to take a look at the resolve.conf.
Default sbccluster.localsbcdot.
What's that name server here?
I'm pretty sure that's the
core d a k d n s service
IP.
Yeah.
Good.
Okay.
But
Looks okay. The resolve dot conf.
Let's go back in the container.
Let's try doing a dig at
mean, that's pretty much the same thing anyway.
This could just be an NDots problem.
Kubernetes.
Svc. Custard
local.
Yeah. That works. Okay.
Yeah. I think the n dot five
I think that was the default. I don't
know.
Cluster DNS
worked though.
Just not with the dots. Let's
change.
Get
I think Justin, sorry, a comment flew past
there.
That's not what I had. I don't know
why it's broken.
Again, I really hate this show. Okay.
Edit core DNS conflict map.
Centimeters.
No end up configuration in here.
Alright.
Let's see.
Duffy says it's not ended. Okay.
And Brent says, look at the search again.
I am assuming
the dig here. Yeah.
So what have we got?
Anything that stands out?
Okay. Just as I said, he changed resolve
conf on the worker nodes and updated the
cubit config map to use my modified result.
Okay.
Yeah. I agree. Definitely. It's interesting.
Cool. But we're kind of like we we
can't really reproduce
the
error or the actual
brokenness. Is that an English word?
I don't know. You know, I was
I I was still sure we we were
gonna do really well today that I brought
myself a victory beer that I don't think
I'm gonna get to drink anymore.
Nice.
Well
Alright. I would say I think that was
fun and we learned something.
How about we
we
prepare ourselves for a little bit more pain?
Yeah. Let's jump onto cluster two. We wanna
make sure we, you know, allocate enough time
to both. Justin has a repository of an
Ansible playbook that he used to break this.
We'll also do the write up in the
post mortem.
So I think we got the first issue,
which Well, we got the service fixed. Thank
you for leaving nice working service on that
directory. The second one was the API token,
which we could fix, but
I can't get an API token right now.
And then the third one is the DNS.
I'm not entirely sure what's broken. I'm really
surprised to see that a deg. Coup, like
a fully resolved
name
works, but not
the, but not with the
fluffy match. I don't even know if that's
a technical term, it's that's no, but I'm
always gonna call it.
Not sure why that's working. I'm looking forward
to seeing the Ansible playbook.
You have a beat, Justin. Well done.
Absolutely.
Alright.
Let's move on to cluster number two, which
is 006
broken
by team SIGHONK.
Alright.
So So, what did we say there? We
first need to
Well, I'm worried.
We have our teleport screen which is only
listing our worker nodes.
Right.
No control plane nodes. No control plane nodes.
Yep. Let me grab an IP address for
one of these control plane nodes.
I have a terminal here.
Let's export the cube config. I know I'm
gonna run and get notes and just hope
that it works, but you know, it's not
looking good.
No. Okay.
You'll need to use the
broadcast view. Wait. Oh, wait. That did work.
Are you sure that you're in the right
oh, yeah. O six. Yeah. I I I
remember that one, being in the right in
the right directory in the for the right
cluster. Right?
That's a gotcha.
But
why is it is that really let me
double check. Is that really
yeah. No. Those are actually everything is
everything is ready. That's too nice. That's
I almost don't believe it. Alright.
Well,
we have an issue report.
Oh, okay. And a directory.
Hi admins. I can see from kubectl get
pods dash a there, pods and things running
on the control play notes.
But when I SSHN,
I can't see anything running.
Signed a confused guess.
Maybe
Specsaver,
if you can't see. But but it only
works in The UK.
Alright.
So
what have we got here?
There are some really nice
are you contained
binaries?
Are
you familiar with are you contained?
I am a little bit. Yes.
Okay.
Has our SSH
process
been replaced?
I feel like I wanna go into the
proc and start digging her in. You know
what? If if sick if sick honk has
replaced that one,
we are really screwed. We have pretty much
no chance to
no. That's
so that's your hypothesis. You you you think
that
the SSH
team is
not what we think it is.
I mean Is that your
I don't know.
Do you think like, I'm
pretty sure We do. Our root fail system
is an overlay fail system. We yeah. This
SSH has not taken us into the host.
Because
our root fail system is an overlay. We've
got
c groups leaking through.
Yeah. This is
interesting.
Let's
run a PSWW.
That should give us that without
cutting anything off. So that's our SSHD binary.
Right.
Which doesn't look right either.
And there's our yeah, we're
I'm not really sure I know where to
start with this one. How do we get
out of this container?
Well, oh, we can do that, right?
Because our cube control worked.
So we can get on the host
with a privileged pod
and fix SSH.
Well,
let's give it a try. Why not? Yeah.
If that is if that is
your hypothesis list, let's check it. Or do
you agree with me? Do you have something
Yeah.
No. That like I haven't seen anything.
Well, I just We
we can run git pods, we can run
git nodes. Our control plane is fine. Obviously,
SSH doesn't work.
We were in a container. They've
got themselves access to the host, replaced SSH.
Right. So I think if we just run
a privileged container,
get onto the host, try and fix SSH.
Right.
I would say let's give it a try,
but I'm
wondering if if they really are
that nice to us.
But we
well, let's give it a try. Why not?
Yeah.
Let's
okay. So let's get a deployment. Yaml. If
we are if we are going on the
wrong path, sec honk, please
interject.
Help us out. Yeah. Yeah. Give give us
a little bit of of feedback if we
are working in the right direction or not.
That would So we can create a deployment.
I know. We can spec this out.
I'm not really caring what it's called. I
don't even care what image we particularly run.
Let's just do
let's just do it out pane.
Duffy just gave us a hint saying proxy
or service and take a peek. Yeah. Why
not?
That's
a low hanging fruit.
Yeah. Shall we do that? Yeah.
So pass our SS agent SS agent through
to one of the working nodes and use
that to go onto one of the other
machines. Is that what we're saying?
Yes. That would work. I mean, think the
plan of running a privileged container and using
that to get onto the host is more
fun. But that would involve Another
hint.
Check your deployment.
We need to see that WordPress site.
Okay.
Right.
Six
days.
Port forward.
Yeah. That's the cluster IP.
I noticed. I used to extend all IP
but Yeah.
It's just I can't remember if I actually
sell working anyways.
Yeah. Of course. Of course. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you. Thanks. Thanks, honk. We have
been Always a pleasure. Honk.
We have been honked.
Okay. So you had your fun. Thank you
very much. I'm I'm kind of like, you
know, trusting in Duffy here. Kind of like,
he he was just messing with us. That
was awesome. Thank you. Okay.
So we can Good thing that'll be full
and paid forward. That's fine. Let's see if
our kind of workers are affected. I'm assuming
with the fact that they're listed and teleport
means they're yeah. They're system d and stuff.
Okay.
How do I how do I put through
my SS agent again? Or how do I
proxy for a machine? I can never remember
the flags for this.
Wow.
Forward agent.
No. Minus
t minus t, was it?
What's the flag?
We could just do forward agent. There must
be a flag for that though.
Scroll up again.
Alright. Thanks for the hint,
Duffy.
So if we go back into this, this
is our I just wanna make sure it's
still the broken one. No, that was the
other one.
Is that the broken one?
Yeah.
Duffy suggested using a different port number.
Oh, it's a small p.
Yeah.
Okay.
Phew.
Okay. We're on the host.
I'm gonna
they disabled my thing. Okay.
Let's get us back onto our shared terminal.
Okay. We have our control plane node.
Okay. Alright. You should be able to join
the session. It's gonna break my screen
maybe.
Let's see.
Did it break anything?
No. It's it's still working.
Looks like it works. Okay.
What create pod objects? Well, a lot a
lot of things create pod objects.
Right? Replication controllers
or replica sets.
Well, let's have a look.
Oh, sorry.
I'll I'll lay off the tape in.
You'll need to set an alias for key
though.
Words.
I can't have control.
And then dash dash kube config slash e
c c kubernetes admin. I
have that somewhere.
Do you want me to do it? You
got it. Yeah. If you if you have
it somewhere.
Putting everything.
I just I I'm I'm getting really good
at typing this one line.
Does it need Yeah. You need yep.
That's right. There you go. Okay. Okay. Cool.
So
Okay.
This is
okay.
And
rapid cassettes.
So
there is
one
that's
so something changed there. Right?
So Six days ago versus forty five hours.
It looks like the scale down my replica
set and then spun up their own replica
set with the desired one, which must be
a broken one.
Mhmm.
Can you do a get replica sets?
Purchase it.
Yeah.
Just that.
Okay.
I think I said
I just did get alright. Does that return?
Yeah.
Right. Oh, that was already doing it. Right.
Okay.
Let's
I mean, I don't I mean, can we
just delete their one and and scale up
our old one?
Like, that would be a Well, if the
deployment
that owns that replica set hasn't been tampered
with, then, you know, one one only lives
once.
Yes. Slash Hammer. Come on. Embrace team slash.
Yeah. Why why not? Right? Do I have
to do yeah. I do have to do
a copy paste here. Right? Yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
So Kubernetes admin cannot delete replica sets.
Nice. Thanks.
So, shall we check our Rawkode binding, our
rule bindings Yeah. For the user?
Yeah.
Yeah. Let's do that.
Alright.
So, we should have a cluster rule
binding.
No. Of course, we're not allowed to do
anything. Right?
Nope. Sorry. I I dual
taping.
Platform. Okay. Anyways.
Let's look at this deployment we've got. Let's
see.
Yeah. You see that he or they didn't
touch
the deployment. Right? The deployment is still the
the original one six days ago.
It's really just a replica set.
Right?
Aren't you rude, love?
There is a yeah.
Duffy taught me this command and he's also
just been very kind enough to put it
here.
The off can I?
Let's see.
So should those be stars
or is Blank also a star?
Oh, no. Wait. We've only got get list
watch and all of this. Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay. Something. Let's
I will not be beaten by Geese.
So
So, there's no touch to adminconf.
Let's check the API server configuration.
The
plot thickens.
So
there must be something here
that is modifying
the way.
Openload our back. Looks okay.
Not privileged.
Do we have any PSPs?
Well, I mean, the image doesn't
look very trustworthy,
does it now?
I mean How's it I missed that?
I mean,
don't take it personally Duffy but
Right?
Yeah.
Maybe let's let's replace that with a proper
like upstream clean,
you know, real API server.
Yeah.
Okay. I actually don't know what that is
off the top of my head to be
fair.
Kubernetes.
Probably cube dash API server but
probably the
the full
URL.
Sneaky bastard.
You're placing the API server there. I'm gonna
assume it's gonna be the one with the
most. No, it's not the one with the
most downloads.
Oh, well, maybe it's just not on Docker
Hub.
Let's check the oh no.
What would our API server be?
I'm gonna look it up. Hold on.
IP address from the other cluster.
That's where it's coming to.
Okay.
So
let me just do this quickly.
Yes.
Kubernetes
manifests
cube API.
The image is very cool.
And
let's go back to our shared terminal. We
can fix it here.
Okay.
Cool.
Now.
Running for 62.
So kill dash one,
not nine. So
Duffy says the rest is fine, which means
we should not trust him and double check
everything else.
Like, that's just that's just me being paranoid.
Okay.
So we've replaced the image
and what you were trying to do prior
to that was delete this new Right. Replica
set. Right. In the hope that
still for a bit. Nice.
Did it pick it up? Do we actually
are we running the new
API server? The sec up may have just
I was
was looking at the
at the chat. I didn't
follow along if you actually
applied that.
Well,
I modified the manifest and I sent a
sec up to the API server, but that
one actually work as the sync up to
the API server.
Can we just do a PS and see?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah. It's it's there, but Oh, yeah.
You know, it's just a thing. I don't
even know if it's using the right image.
Now,
when we try and speak to the API
server, we could be getting thrown to a
different machine. So, I guess we're gonna have
to SSH onto the other ones and fix
the image there too.
So, me grab the IP addresses.
Okay.
So,
SSH
port
Kubernetes
manifests
API server
that he changed them all,
that they changed them all. Sorry, forget your
team just because Duffy's comment.
Copy
that.
Good.
Okay.
Let's restart this one.
Yeah. Why not? One more tab and we
need to do the other control plane node.
Now, we also found a subtitle for clustered.
It's the sledgehammer parade.
Alright. Manifest.
Kip APIs there were image.
Delete
and copy the image name.
There we go.
This
proves it again.
Kubernetes engineers are YAML engineers.
Okay.
Hopefully,
that's like I I mean I I'm not
entirely sure that that's a cup is actually
doing
an image pool, but we can run a
get r s.
Must be the wrong one.
Wrong one.
Oh, no. It's in teleport. No.
Delete RS.
No. Okay. So that setup may not actually
be pulling or expecting the image. It could
just be restarting the process.
William suggested
let's try running the auth
again.
Good idea.
We still got get list watch. So let's
assume the hypothesis here is that the sec
hop Well, we has to change the image.
We
don't have delete. That's why we can't delete
it. We only have get list watch.
Much. Duffies will just look in this file
again.
Quite a blatant
hint. Wow.
Okay. So I knew there. Mean
What we wanna do is check our kubelet
configuration.
Let's see if the static manifest path has
been changed.
Let's look at the kubeletconf.
Won't be anything in there actually, that's silly.
So we need to look in the
flags
and maybe this configuration
or if I is it this one?
I don't know. I'll just check them all.
You fail. Alright. Next.
This one.
Manifest.
Nope.
Alright. Let's check the flags,
etcetera, default.
What was that out there?
Oh, garlic.
It's probably
Nothing.
Where would the static manifest?
Where's that path configured?
Must be one of those files we've looked
in. Let's run a status
on our kubelet.
This
service file.
Oh, wait, there's logs there too.
I feel like I'm chasing my tail.
Brent just pointed out container
path looked off. Okay.
Alright. So
did I miss that in the
the configs?
I certainly missed it.
Whatever. Let's let's make I
searched for manifest. I should have set for
static. Okay.
Right. Well, we've already updated the image and
I don't wanna have to do that again.
So I'm going back to this. Yeah.
Kudos
to Eagle Eye.
Thank
you very much.
Alright. And then we
will need to restart the kubelet because of
that. We
have a new API server.
We still have no permissions.
And do we have a new API server?
Is that nineteen seconds or nineteen minutes? That's
Nineteen minutes. Okay.
That's still the old one. Right?
Eighteen o five. That was the old one.
Yeah.
Yeah. That looks better.
Alright. Let's give it a try.
Nope.
I guess we're gonna have to update them
all. I
love how it keeps on my actual SSH
session. It keeps sending me messages.
Well,
you have
What was that fail called? It was the
barlep tuplet. Okay. I think no one.
No problem. Yeah.
Config
static.
Oh, that one's okay.
Vembar
the
kubelet config
static.
Yep. That one's broken.
I am not frustrated.
No, I definitely am.
It's like, I think every time someone has
broken a cluster, they have like, maybe it's
just me. Right? But I I don't think
I would break all of the the control
plane nodes. I think I would be more
forgiving than that. Everyone
has been on it as a breaker has
been so consistent in their
their breaks.
Mean.
Yeah. They are mean, aren't they?
Kubernetes
manifest.
Okay. Hang on. Hang on.
No. That's o o six.
Okay.
I will earn this beer. Alright.
Okay. All those Oh, you mean the home.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see how that goes. Oh, yeah. One
of the machines ah. This is Justin's wall
command. Okay. So one of my machines Now
now I got it as well. Alright. Well,
hopefully that's them all fixed.
I don't even know anymore. What day is
it? So
API server.
Okay.
So let me just close that with three.
Like, go away.
Config.
Let's try from another machine and see if
we're getting a little bit better success.
Oh, can I?
No, we're still getting the same thing across
them all.
So even though we have a new API
server with the correct manifests
It looks like
nothing but love or heart. Heart, is that
a hint?
Duffy said he has nothing but
heart or love. I don't know which it
is for you. I'm not sure if that's
a hint.
Yeah.
Not there.
Just making sure it wasn't overwritten on the
command line items or something.
So
we're still trying to figure out if we're
actually
talking with clean
API service. Right?
I think something
yeah. They pass over, not the kubelet. You
need to hack the output, which output or
the the
yeah, which output.
There's an additional role that gives you view,
but we
do
view. Right?
Oh.
Oh, so ah, okay. Now I get it.
Yeah. Okay.
Gotcha.
So that So do we think this is
gonna work?
Hey.
Confusing ourselves there by not viewing the top
of the can I output? Yeah. Sorry. You
can be kind. Thank you.
Yes. They are right, Ian.
It's it's your your combined
evilness. It's not just
individuals.
Right? Alright. So we have deleted They conquer
making us Wait.
Did it come up again?
Okay. So
let's do get service
port forward.
Oh no. Why am I doing this here?
Zero zero six export to config port forward
WordPress. Do I at least have my normal
WordPress back?
Yes.
Let's see. No. Nope.
I've pressed That
would have been too easy.
Why not?
Oh, no. Because it's skilled then.
Yeah. This is the deployment, doesn't it?
Deployment.
No.
Edit, deploy
WordPress.
Replicas one.
Okay. So the
I guess we can just make an artificial
change.
Oh no. We can just fix the actual
image.
WordPress.
I can't remember if that's the right image.
Let's find out.
We've got a new replica set. Desired as
one.
That should be pulling the image.
I'm confident.
Hopefully.
I better. I guess I should confirm the
image is definitely called WordPress. In fact, I
have it locally.
We deploy workload
automated here.
Teamwork makes the dream work. Yep. I agree
with them.
Woah. Why is it trying to open it?
Computers,
just hate them.
Yeah. Yeah.
I can totally agree.
Alright. That I said damaged the right thing.
Close enough. Okay. I
think the problem
is something else. So we took our s.
Yeah. That's definitely.
Oh, hang on.
I'm gonna set the tool policy to always
in case they've messed with something there too.
Okay.
And I'm gonna set that up just to
force it.
So how do we think this is going?
Awesome.
Alright. So something is wrong.
Scrape,
deploy
WordPress.
We've got our scaling events.
But there are no pods. Right? Oh, you're
you're on the
Yeah. We're not getting any pods. I think
we need to take a look at
cubit logs.
Do you think that they maybe
even replace the controller manager?
Maybe?
Screwing with the
replica set.
Shall we have a look?
We got a few errors here but I'm
now at a stage of delusion of debugging
this. I have no idea what is a
real symptom and what is
is noise.
Well,
Okay. We we take hint.
What's going on here? What turns the replica
set into pods? Well, deployments for example. Right?
So,
if we looked at the deployment We're not
getting any pods showing up.
So
Right. But I guess what Duffy hinted at
was that
there's something wrong with the deployment.
That's my interpretation.
Should we get the logs on the controller
manager?
I guess. I
think he
literally meant just the
the WordPress deployment. Right?
No. I think we have fixed that. I
think we have a replica set that's being
created. I think then the controller manager's
not able or
not Okay. Doing something with that to create
the pods.
Okay. Let's test that. But
why is it
cube system
get pods
log dash f.
Why did that not get any logs? Oh,
there we go.
Okay. We do have a problem.
Okay.
So,
We're getting a connection refused when the controller
manager is trying to speak to.
Okay. So cannot get resource endpoints.
Right.
But that looks more like an RPIC issue,
no?
So
I think
Let's take a look at the cube controller
manager.
Okay. Deploy.
Oh, it's a static manifest, isn't it?
Yeah. What's the change here? Look look look
out for honks.
Right? Always look out for honks.
That would've been too easy. The image looks
okay.
It's like conquer off my Christmas card list
from now on.
Okay. So that is that nothing wrong with
the controller manager permissions or binary.
Okay.
Well, that's
good and
bad.
Right. Deployment deployment controller, replica set replica set
controller.
So
but the replica set
controller is part of the controller manager. Right?
I it is. Yeah. As far as I
know. So
those controllers,
though. Yeah.
Bad controllers.
What
are we looking at?
User system cube controller manager cannot get resource
endpoint.
This beer was supposed to be a victory
beer. Now it's a consolidation beer.
Alright.
Yes, Ian. I will
I will get you a card
for all major holidays.
So
let's get back to the the
replica
set
controller.
Controller.
What?
What's the star?
I do not know.
I mean, should we even be overriding the
controllers? If I had move that, is it
gonna default to something sensible?
Will we comment that out and see what
happens? Sure. Kubernetes has absolutely same
default. Why not? I mean, I'm just I'm
absolutely
I'm guessing I mean, it's worse than I
guess now, to be honest.
Alright. Let's see.
Where's our controller manager? It has been running.
Okay. It's been restarted now. So,
do we have any pods?
No.
Wait.
Oh, that's my SQL. Yeah.
Okay. So maybe we don't have sensible defaults
here.
Oh, wait. So It's a dash replica set.
It's so small I cannot Oh, I I
can actually
because that mean don't run the replica set
controller.
I've never used that syntax before.
Did it restart yet?
Don't know off the top of my head
if that is the case. Oh, now I
don't have a controller manager.
Oh, no. It's back. Okay. Do I have
pods?
Maybe
it's just not ready yet.
Thought sure that was gonna be it.
Yeah. Let's let's
let's follow valid advice
regarding the manifest. Let's go back to the
manifest and double check again.
The options there.
Yeah. I don't like that star.
Should it all be star?
You know what? Have a let's have a
look at the actual dogs.
I I was told that this is a
lot of fun. Let me have a look
at the
at the reference here. Kubernetes.
That's the
control.
Oh yeah, star is a sensible default. Okay.
So, of controllers to enable star, enables all
owned by default controllers, foo enables controller foo,
dash foo disables foo.
Okay. Let's go with so if we ah,
right. Got it. So by setting
any of them here except for just star,
that'll be deleted there. So the default should
have been Yeah. Just
just do star which is the default which
means all.
Right? That's what the docs say. I guess
this might not be the active control plane
controller.
So, I really need to do this on
the other two machines as well.
Right.
Which is probably why, in fact, removing it
should run the default and I think the
reason I never got the default behavior when
I tested it last time was purely because
it wasn't the leader. So that's j g.
That's the six w,
which means I need to get onto the
machine. Let me look over here.
P. Alright. Just this one.
Yeah. I know William. This is it's a
it almost feels like cheating. Right? Looking at
the dogs and actually RTFM,
we need to find manual.
That's
I know.
Yeah. That was a good idea. I'm not
sure how long I would have given that
before I gave Keith then and finally reached
for the dog. I should just get in
the habit of doing that sooner. Alright.
All of our controller managers
should hopefully have restarted and I'm not I'm
gonna ask them the default should okay. So
k get pods.
Duffy asks how many controller managers do you
have? Well, how many do we need?
I
wonder how far behind the comments are. I
feel like
they're giving me advice right after I say
something.
Time stamp looks okay.
Oh, wait. Controller manager.
Okay. 32.
Ta da.
Well done.
Great job, David.
Well, let's not let's not, you know, we're
not yet allowed to grab a pint because
we wanna see we wanna see if we
have been de honked. Right?
Duffy, I'm not that sure if if if
I agree that's oh, there you go. That's
what
is it? But is it? Oh, I don't
I don't think once you said? Let's
let's let's move on to the next.
I think Yeah. I I bet that you
you you folks have a lot of fun
seeing us sweating here, our pants
for how we doing time work. I didn't
realize it was still dark in my room.
Oh, damn it. Let me quickly let
me quickly
Alright. SecHonk, please let us know if we
got everything there. Is there anything else we
need to look at? Oh, so Michael, you've
got a hard stop. I'm sorry. We went
two minutes I
just
it's a fucking wrap up.
Alright. So let's
those were two great clusters there.
Right. I think we had a a very
varied set of problems there.
I'm not sure we've fixed everything
on Justin's cluster. Cluster. I'm looking forward to
reading the Ansible playbook and
compiling that post mortem together to really show
what happened and how to fix it. It
looks like we have some sort of weird
discrepancy between what's happening on the teleport SSH
versus the standard SSH.
So something I just I
just say hi to Bartek who was so
kind joining us now.
I'll be over in a a moment. That
was really fun. Thanks a lot. That I
I I definitely learned a lot, like, how
mean people can be. So and
and hope it was useful and and fun
for others as well. I certainly have. Alright.
Well, thank you, Justin, teams like Honk, and
Michael for joining me today.
It it's so challenging being on this site.
I thought like, you were so calm. I
don't know how you how you just keep
so collected through that. Like, inside my head,
I am literally screaming all the worst words
in the world to our breakers. So
I I learned stuff today about some of
the configuration and stuff. And that's the point
of this. So thank you to our breakers.
We're
all learning together and hopefully having some fun
while we do it. Michael, thank you again
for spending this session with me, and I
will speak to you soon. Thanks to everyone
who joined I've not seen who won the
but whoever it was, congratulations.
Alright. Thanks a lot. Bye bye. Cheers. Bye
now.